he is the Academy Award winner Denzel
Washington how you been Denzel
I'm great how are you I'm better for
talking to you now if I recall you're a
Cowboys fan is that correct that's
correct okay what are your thoughts on
the current predicament of the gentleman
with the stars on this side of their
helmet I can't say it's a rebuilding
year but you know there's no testimony
without a test I don't know where I got
that from but there's no testimony so we
got we got to go through it and
hopefully we'll grow through it as well
yeah it's us sound like something from
Remember the Titans I got to be honest
with you that does sound like something
that Coach Boone would actually say
there's no sir I don't know where I got
that there's no testimony without a test
I like that a lot
I like that a man with it I will take it
how did you become a Cowboys fan when
did that first start the the Red Raiders
I played for the Red Raiders in the boys
club when I was a little kid and we used
to shift you know they'd call we got up
to the line of scrimmage we would raise
up and shift and move and the Cowboys
did the same thing so I was convinced
that eight years old that they got it
from us like all the cowboys run the
same offense we do so I always you know
been a fan ever since and even in the
times when you were there in the city
and you know he's the other thing too
because I was running back and because I
had speed speed guys like Bob Hayes or
or you know and then get great great
running backs what was it what was it
what was their word a running back who
didn't talk much in in the Dwayne tommix
yep that's Emma Duane Thomas horse yeah
yeah man Duane Thomas and then obviously
all the greats but always been a not
everybody remembers Duane Thomas no you
just did yeah he was very II was
controversial cuz he wouldn't speak hmm
which definitely for for America's team
was was unique there's no question about
that man I love that you thought the
Cowboys maybe at one point during the
Red Raiders practice you saw a man with
a fedora on the sideline photo
Landry and daughter was Landry maybe
that's what it was Denzel Washington
here on the Rich Eisen show so what is
your favorite sports movie where would
you go with that because so many people
would take a look at some that you've
been in and peg like I just mentioned
remember the time Emma tonight a lot of
people like that my son he grew up on
Rudy mm-hmm he was Rudy 50 times I don't
know I'm trying to think of I don't
remember having one growing up that I
always like my go-to I don't know what
was the big sports movie from the 60s or
70s well obviously you'd have bang the
drum slowly would be one or Brian's song
yeah that's true but what about anything
contemporary Hoosiers of you got losers
was great what do you think of Bull
Durham do you ever see Bull Durham Bowl
Durham was great but a for some reason I
don't think of that as a sports movie
but why is that I don't know I just
think of the guy in the girl okay you
think it's a love story when I think of
the love tour I'll tell you this Denzel
I always think Rocky's a love story I
don't look at right how can we not how
could we leave our rocky you know I
would just look at one of those things
too you know yeah you don't think of
that as a sports story know you don't
know I always did something else Denzel
Washington of Roman J Israel Esquire
again in theaters near you starting on
Thanksgiving Day right here on the Rich
Eisen show what would you think you play
Jake Shuttlesworth obviously and he got
game what do you think Jake would say
about levar balls parenting skills
Denzel well he's from the same school
right that's interesting but but but I
could I could hear him saying to his
wife I told you you shouldn't have gone
to college go to college yeah sounds
like the same right they seem cut from
the same cloth same cloth that's right
are you paying attention at all the
lonzo's trials tribulations or what
what's going on with you no he's got to
go through it and and and and
unfortunately for him guys are out to
get him now you know because of
all the chitter chatter you know but I
think he just needs to stick with his
game you know and I think he's gonna
have to work on a shot in the offseason
you know I think he's gonna have to
change a shot why is that well because
he's easy to time he's bringing it all
the way from his hip and that's a long
way from your hip to your shoulder and
so you're given the defense too much
time do you still have Lakers season
tickets yes I do
III was at the game when McHale
clothesline Rambis back in the whatever
that was eighty something okay and I've
got season tickets that day we got
scalped tickets we spent too much money
for the tickets man Robert Townsend and
we saw that game and we went upstairs
and signed up for season ticket because
Rambis could take a punch or yes because
it was so exciting and it was it was it
was the place to be and we just signed
up that day right I mean it was at the
Forum and they used to call him Senate
seats we signed up for Senate Senate
seats because it was because the whole
thing like the Roman senators I guess
and all then I guess okay and what's
your relationship with magic just having
obviously been around Los Angeles as
long as you've had and him being as
popular in this cities as ever
Dennis magic is you know he's always
been just when you say his name you
smile hmm it's always been that he's
always been that a no no a long time
we're neighbors and and I'm just trying
to say nice things because I'm hoping it
alone me some money I know neighbors boy
do you have a couple of dollars he's
done all right a little bit there's no
doubt all right like what like like look
neighbors down the street literally
literally the neighbors yeah yeah so if
denzel washington needs a cup of sugar
or a world with him magic house and get
a cup of sugar antastic
what attracted you to this current role
Denzel Roman Jay Israel Esquire just
well written something I hadn't read
before a character I haven't played
before
and and just Dan Gilroy is a wonderful
writer and it was real easy when I read
it I was like man I wanted this I just
wanted to go down that road so that
spoke to you I mean how do you view a
script when it comes right there on your
lens there's no one way you know it's a
little bit too you know you're not
looking to do something you just did mm
so that was coming off a plane the
dominant father and in in in fences Tori
maxes so this was completely different
than that and and just well-written just
a good good story good script and I
guess the fact that you weren't
directing does that after you have
directed yes that's helping that you're
that you know that it's I guess just a
little bit responsibility yeah less
responsibility yeah in there and he
wrote Nightcrawler which was a great bag
of Jake Gyllenhaal all the exactly so
all right Denzel look I really
appreciate you taking the time and
calling into the show enjoy your
Thanksgiving enjoy the holidays we hope
you see you back on NFL Network real
soon okay take care
you got Denzel Washington here the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience